Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Liebe. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich habe mir überlegt, wir könnten ja mal Sondierungsgespräche aufnehmen.
Ist doch jetzt zu spät, die sind doch vorbei.
Raschel, raschel, raschel, raschel. Hier wird schon wieder gemauselt und geraschelt.
Kannst du mal kannst du mal ganz kurz riechen, ob die noch gut ist?
Na ja, so riecht das dann. So riecht das dann.
Boah! Die sind aber echt. Meinst du echt? Nee.
Du schnupperst schon mal in der Großen Koalition.
Wo kommt die jetzt? Fukushima oder was? Benjamin.
Das ist äh.
Ist das so ein Trockenobstkram? Nee.
Eingeschweißt äh japanische Pflaume, das einwandfrei. Wir haben heute einen Gast.
Das kann man schon essen, genau. Ja, wir haben einen Gast, wir haben uns äh in der Oppositionspartei eingekauft hier. Na, Linus, hast du an der zukünftigen Demokratie geleckt? Ist ein bisschen sauer, was?
Sah aber sehr schön aus, als es noch verpackt war, oder?
Weiß nicht, warum du Dinger loswerden willst. Ja, ist doch mal eine leckere japanische Pflaume.
Ich will ihn nicht, ich finde das, ich finde das lecker. Man kann sich an alles gewöhnen, ne. Ja, Benjamin, äh hallo, Benjamin Bergemann, du warst ja äh schon mal hier äh vor ein paar Ausgaben. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau welche, aber das finden wir sicherlich bald raus,
und ähm ja, du bist immer noch sehr umtriebig im äh netzpolitischen äh Feld, schreibst für Netzpolitik Punkt org, unter anderem,
was du sonst noch so machst, aber das tust du auf jeden Fall.
Genau, sonst mache ich halt das Gleiche bei digitale Gesellschaft, so äh eher so Pressemitteilungen statt Blogartikel sozusagen und ansonsten studiere ich eigentlich hier in Berlin Politikwissenschaft.
Also bist voll in der Spur.
Genau, ich bin vorhin in der Spur.
Das äh trifft sich gut, weil wir wollen ja hier auch wieder in die Spur kommen. Stimmt's? Du bist so ein bisschen aufgehalten, gerade mit Gadgets und äh Essensfotografien. Das ist so Hipster-Style, ne? So Kamera rausziehen und so.
So eine, so eine eingeschweißte ekelhafte Traube.
Ist nicht ekelhaft. Das ist eine japanische Pflaume.
Kann man nur fotografieren. Soll ich die jetzt essen oder was?
Du machst doch, was du äh willst, aber.
Eine Demokratiepflaume.
Ja, eine Koalitionsplaume.
Koalitionsver.
So schmeckt sie auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich übe einfach schon mal so ein bisschen diesen, wie nennt man das, äh wenn man so Humor macht, um sich aus einer prekären Situation mental zu befreien?
Humor, genau. Das war's. Ich übe schon mal den Geigenhumor, weil ich habe so diesen Eindruck, den brauchen wir.
Wenn wir brauchen, ja.
Jahren. Ja, den werden wir auf jeden Fall brauchen.
Wer hat uns jetzt, also die, wer hat jetzt uns verraten? Die.
Das wird sich noch zeigen, aber ich glaube, da gibt's so die üblichen Kandidaten. Die sich da schon mal aufstellt so.
Ja, die SPD, genau, also das ist das ist auf jeden Fall die Koalitions-SPD hat sich das ja schon auch eine Meldung nach allen, nach den Sondierungsgesprächen hat sich die SPD jetzt entschieden, doch auch in Koalitions äh Verhandlungen mit der CDU einzutreten.
Sieht danach aus, dass wir tatsächlich die große Koalition bekommen, die wir alle befürchtet haben. Das ist ja auch,
Auch mal erwähnen, oder? Guck mal, jetzt schreibt der Tim nämlich hier ist heute ein nicht gut. Nächstes Mal lassen wir das mit den Pflaumen sein und dann.
Ich bin absolut multitaskingfähig. Wie ist es mit dir?
Ich installiere nebenbei hier noch ein neues US Alter.
Na ja, also ihr äh merkt schon alle, wir sind hier äh entspannt und üben uns im gepflegten Humor. Man kann ja auch nochmal sagen, wo äh alle reingeschaltet haben, weil wer weiß das schon so ganz genau. Man tippt ja heutzutage einfach nur noch so aufm Smartphone und sagt, spiel mal was,
Ihr seid äh selbstverständlich angekommen bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik. Der zweiundachtzigsten äh Ausgabe.
Vom dreiundzwanzigsten Oktober.
Bevor wir vom dreiundzwanzigsten Oktober zwanzig dreizehn und bevor wir uns hier weiter mit Inlands Thematiken deprimieren lassen, hauen wir doch erstmal ein bisschen aufs Ausland ein, oder?
Ausland, in dem ich übrigens auch gerade war, ähm Frankreich wird von der NSA überwacht,
Die Franzosen sind empört und zwar äh
wie immer, wie es für NSA-Überwachung so üblich ist, wurde äh keine Unterscheidung getroffen, ob das jetzt Bürger oder Unternehmen sind, die man da äh abhört und es wurde sich auch nicht nur auf eine Technik beschränkt
und es gibt dann so eine schöne Zahl, die äh besagt, dass zwischen Dezember zwanzig zwölf und Januar zwanzig dreizehn, also einem Zeitraum, der,
Äh mindestens dreißig maximal neunundfünfzig
oder einundsechzig Tage zweiundsechzig Tage umschreiben kann, siebzig Millionen äh Telefonate aufgezeichnet wurden.
Ja, also in zwei Monaten, um das mal ein bisschen einfacher zu formulieren.
Es könnte auch nur einer sein.
Ja. Was? Ach so. Ach so, weil das so unklar äh der Zeitraum unklar genannt wurde.
Mit mindestens zweiunddreißig. Ja, ich bin ein bisschen müde. Ähm und irgendwie SMS und Metadaten haben sie auch interessiert und alles weggeschrieben und gespeichert.
Und sie haben äh laut diesen Unterlagen, die sich natürlich aus dem Fundus von AdWord Snowden speisen, auch Kooperationen mit den dortigen Netzbetreibern ähm,
und untersuchen outgoing E-Mail von dem Netz äh Anbieter One Doo, das irgendwie,
Okay, das äh eine Orange-Tochter habe ich gelesen, oder? Der wurde von Orange irgendwie geschluckt und,
Was mich ein bisschen wundert, weil ist ja Infrastrukturhersteller. Also sie bauen ja Geräte,
Die bauen ja ähm kenne ich hauptsächlich daher, dass sie äh ähm Elemente für mobile Netzwerke bauen,
Das ist eine was weiß ich, BTS, Pipapo, Core.
Betreiben keine Netze.
Die betreiben kein Netz, nee, die verkaufen Netz.
Aussage in diesen Berichten.
Nee, war's auch nicht, aber wie kriegen die die Outgoing E-Mail von Al Catellose hin? Also das.
Ich freue mich schon, wie sie überhaupt die Telefonate innerhalb von Frankreich äh bekommen, also an welcher Stelle sitzen äh die, ich meine, das ist ja die Frage, die wir uns ja auch bei Deutschland äh bei den Berichten bereits gestellt haben, ja? Und es ist ja äh in dem Sinne,
Hab ich was verpasst? Also irgendwie ist es irgendwie immer noch nicht so richtig klar wo eigentlich äh am Drops gelutscht wird.
Ja, also es es die Hypothesen bleiben die gleichen, dass sie an irgendwo an an den Glasfasern hängen, das leuchtet natürlich ein
oder dass sie irgendwo an Netzknoten entsprechende Monitoring entsprechendes Monitoring betreiben. Und es war auch in einem Artikel davon die Rede, dass sie das teilweise
mit mit Hilfe von finanzieller Kompensation der jeweiligen Netzbetreiber auch realisieren.
Ja, in den USA, aber doch nicht in Frankreich.
Weil davon war jetzt hier die Rede in dem Artikel, den ich gelesen habe. Wobei ich mir's auch nicht vorstellen kann, dass ein französischer Netzbetreiber sagt, ja, alles klar, hier, äh.
Mal Geld, dann spionieren wir für euch.
Denn nee, halte ich auch für unwahrscheinlich.
Auch für sehr unwahrscheinlich. Von daher.
Also es es bleiben die alten äh also deswegen wundert's mich ja auch, dass sie ausgerechnet einen diesen einen Provider benennen und andererseits dann noch diese diesen äh Netzwerkequipment-Hersteller, ja. Ähm.
Ähm.
Das sind das sind also das macht für mich jetzt auch wenig Sinn, während diese siebzig Millionen Telefonate aufgezeichnet, das äh macht halt äh,
Das macht Sinn, ja.
Aber ich verstehe einfach immer noch nicht so richtig, an welcher Stelle die sitzen.
Ja, was man vielleicht noch bemerken sollte, ist ja, dass Frankreich auch doppelt überwacht wird. Wir hatten ja im Sommer,
Ja, im Sommer auch so ziemlich in der Frühphase dieser Snowden-Meldung hatten wir ja schon mal die Meldung, dass äh der französische Geheimdienst selbst äh massiv solche Erhebungen durchführt
das waren auch ähnliche Sachen, hab's jetzt nicht genau am Kopf und der Witz daran ist ja, dass es entweder doppelt gemacht wird,
oder es gibt so eine ähm ähnliche Kooperation wie zwischen BND und NSA in Deutschland, weil nämlich in dem Artikel, den ich hier gerade offen habe, stellt der fest, dass dieser,
äh Codename für dieses Programm in Frankreich sehr ähnlich dem Code Name für das Programm zwischen der BND NSA Kooperation in Deutschland ist.
Welcher war das nochmal?
Das ist in Frankreich, es ist US neunhundertfünfundachtzig D,
Während der äh BND äh NSA-Code für Germany war, US neunhundertsiebenundachtzig LA, also sehr,
Sehr nah beieinander. Also man könnte vielleicht auch davon ausgehen, dass da ein Zusammenhang besteht, dass da die französischen Geheimdienste auch,
mehr mit der NSA zusammenarbeiten, als jetzt dieser Artikel suggerieren.
Da wurde genau auf aufgrund dieser Benennung der Themen äh der
dieser ähm Überwachungstechniken äh wurde dann vermutet, dass es gab ja damals als es losging, das Geschrei darum, dass Deutschland als äh dritter Partner, dritter Partner bezeichnet wurde, also als ähm,
Quelle und es scheint wohl so zu sein aufgrund dieser gleichen Benennung, dass Frankreich auch eine eine ein drittklassiger Partner, also eine Quelle ist während,
Partner erster Stufe dann äh oder Quellen erster Stufe die eigenen die eigenen anderen US-Dienste sind. Die zweite Stufe englischsprachige äh Freunde, also die Five Eyes,
Und äh der die dritte Klasse sind dann eben die ähm.
Ja gut, dann ist, das würde ja die dritte Klasse in gewisser Hinsicht dann schon wieder auf äh werten in der Reihenfolge, dass natürlich ihre Five Eis Geschichte da äh
klar hinter den eigenen Primärerkenntnissen steht klar, ne? Damit ist eigentlich die ist es immer noch die Bronzemedaille.
Es wundern noch andere, äh es wundern noch andere ähm Dinge benannt in Artikeln und zwar, dass sie verschiedene,
verschiedene Techniken einsetzen, also unter anderem auch ähm,
und zwar, dass sie von sich wohl behaupten, in dem Projekt Jeannie ähm Konzepte zu äh zu unterhalten, die auch über äh physisch isolierte Anlagen ähm,
Also auch physisch isolierte Anlagen befallen können. Also eine Myware, die äh sagen wir, du baust jetzt irgendwie besonders wichtige Infrastruktur so auf, dass sie nicht mit dem Internet verbunden ist,
Und ähm das erinnert natürlich dann an an äh Stucksnett. Den äh das die Mywere, die,
vermutlich oder relativ offensichtlich gebaut wurde, um die iranischen Atom an Urananreicherungs,
Fugen zu stören,
und äh da zu diesem Zweck eben von infizierten Rechnern wiederum über USB-Sticks versucht hat, andere Rechner zu infizieren, um sich dann dort auf dem System umzuschauen, zu gucken, ob hier zufällig eine iranische
Uranzentrifuge betrieben wird und diese dann in ihrem in ihrer Funktion zerstören.
Nicht nur zu stören, sondern so äh anzusteuern, dass sie dabei potenziell zerstört.
Kaputt geht oder äh nicht die Qualität liefert, die notwendig ist ähm in der Anreicherung. Ähm.
Also solche Systeme, solche, solche Typen von so wird er in diesen äh Le Mondeartikeln nahegelegt, seien auch zum Einsatz gekommen,
Beim Angriff auf französische Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen, was ich mir wiederum auch nicht so gut vorstellen kann. Also ich halte diese diese,
Die Faktenbasis ähm erscheint mir da so ein bisschen komisch und widersprüchlich. Aber diese Zahl mit den äh siebzig Millionen,
Telekommunikationsdaten, die erscheint da ja eher ähm relativ unstrittig und ähm ich würde,
auch vermuten, wie Benjamin das auch gerade schon nahegelegt hat, dass es nicht gelingt, das zu tun, ohne mit dem jeweiligen Inlandsgeheimdienst zu kooperieren.
Also ohne das Wissen von irgendjemandem und im Zweifelsfall dem Geheimdienst schaffst du's einfach nicht, diese Menge an Daten abzugreifen und aus dem Land zu kratzen, ohne dass äh dass es irgendjemand mitbekommt.
Du meinst die Franzosen reagieren jetzt nur deshalb so empört um den Eindruck äh zu erwecken, dass sie ja davon gar nichts gewusst haben.
Schmeckt's?
Ich wollte mich nochmal ein bisschen aufheitern hier, nochmal.
Ja
Von der Demokratie probieren,
Ich weiß es nicht. Also die sind sich ja jetzt, die zecken sich ja jetzt oft ähm öffentlich, relativ übel an, also Hologne findet ja sehr scharfe Worte. Sie haben jetzt sogar gesagt, jetzt wollen wir mal den den Botschafter ja dann doch mal.
Einbestellen.
Einbestellen. Na ja, also sie sind ja jetzt fast aufm, meinen sie überholen da jetzt bald Deutschland, ne?
Rechts überholen.
Auf einer rechts so, ja Pofalla muss man rückwärts überholen, aber ähm also sie sie machen irgendwie sie,
Sie kommen jetzt langsam in die Gänge, sich da mal zu beklagen. Und es wäre natürlich jetzt ein bisschen peinlich für die, wenn sich rausstellt, dass diese siebzig Millionen Daten äh und Telefonaufzeichnungen, was ja nicht alles äh ist äh,
tatsächlich unter.
Eigenen Aufzeichnungen sind.
Unter mithilfe der französischen Dienste oder Regierungen.
Na ja, also irgendein Franzose muss da ja schon mitgeholfen haben, sonst kann ich mir irgendwie nicht so richtig vorstellen, äh an welcher Stelle sie solche massiven Abhörmaßnahmen etablieren.
Also dieses interessant finde ich, dass da eben der Name Alcatel Lucien drin vorkommt und sie, ich meine, die bauen halt äh Core-Netzwerke auch und ähm.
Dass sie die einfach so weit infiltriert haben, dass sie da Mallorca in den Geräten drin haben, dass quasi in diesem Equipment bereits schon.
Nee, das muss keine sein. Also die ähm.
Ich muss jetzt kurz gucken, wie ich das am besten ausdrücke, ohne irgendwas zu verletzen. Ähm also diese Geräte haben natürlich auch äh grundsätzlich äh Funktionalitäten,
für Low Intercept und zur Erfassung ihrer Performan.
Ja eh, ne?
Und genau, also die Geräte haben ja diese haben solche Funktionen ja grundsätzlich. Und ähm.
Wenn man einen Weg findet, diese Funktionalitäten zu aktivieren, ohne dass sie einen eigentlichen, intendierten.
Sagen wir mal so, sie sind im Zweifel, sie sind im Zweifelsfall ohnehin äh aktiviert und wenn man einen Weg findet, daran zu partizipieren,
dann sollte das nicht so schwer sein. Also denkbar ist zum Beispiel, dass du jetzt sich mal.
Geister, die ich rief, ja.
Ja ich gehe also die also es wird sicherlich nicht ein Netzwerk betrieben werden, ohne äh die entsprechende Funktionalität für Lorful Intercept ähm aktiviert zu haben. Allein schon von der,
inländischer Idee heraus, ja? Also ähm in vielen Ländern, vielleicht kennen die gesetzliche Lage in Frankreich nicht äh so genau, weil wenn meisten Ländern ist es ja so, dass du diese Überwachungsschnittstellen,
grundsätzlich mitliefern muss, wenn du so ein Netz betreibst und das entsprechend natürlich auch aktiviert ist. Und ähm von dem, was da jetzt,
gemeldet ist, halte ich die Hypothese
Für am naheliegendsten, dass der, dass die NSA da einfach an dem Teil mit äh partizipiert, den die französischen Dienste oder Strafverfolgungsbehörden da ohnehin ähm,
ja, erzwingen. Von den Netzbetreibern. Das wäre jetzt so meine Hypothese auf auf Basis dessen, was da so.
Ja, aber die Franzosen wurden jetzt nicht nur in Frankreich äh überwacht, sondern auch außerhalb.
Ja genau, das äh aber das ist ja auch Klassiker, ne? Französische Botschaft in Washington verwandst
den Angriff auf die Telefonanlage, den wir jetzt inzwischen kennen, äh von von der UN ähm die französische UNO-Delegation äh haben von der haben sie Screenshots,
Was auch das wird, also das ist eine offensichtlich ja dann, ja, also wir,
und das wird jetzt also ich meine, das das,
So läuft's. Also ganz, ganz offensichtlich dieses Land ist außer Rand und Band und äh.
Deutschland kann sich ja schon äh glücklich schätzen, dass sie quasi mit Frankreich jetzt auf einer Stufe sind, ne?
Weil natürlich die Franzosen, was so ihre äh ihre Involviertheit in das internationale Weltgeschehen betrifft, schon noch in einer anderen Liga spielen, als die Deutschen.
Na ja, vielleicht haben sie sich das Eigentor geschossen als damals die Fritten in USA umbenannt wurden, weil die Franzosen irgendein ja also was sie da,
Jetzt wissen sie, jetzt sehen sie, was sie davon haben, ja. Den war ja offensichtlich nicht mehr zu trauen.
Oh Mann. Freedom-Price. Die heißen aber nicht mehr so jetzt, ne?
Ich meine nicht, nee. Ich habe also ich habe keine Freedom Prece bestellt, als ich letztes Mal da,
Ich glaube, die heißen einfach jetzt. Das ja genau, also dieses Freedom war denen auch zu blöd, aber irgendwie das French wieder dranzuschreiben, ging auch nicht mehr. Ich glaube, die heißen einfach, ja.
Das war's zum Thema Frankreich.
Wir dürfen gespannt sein. Sind ja jetzt erst, ist ja jetzt erst seit zwei Tagen öffentlich.
Genau, also wir beobachten auch weiterhin die Empörung. Mal schauen, wie es so äh rangeht.
Ja, die NSA äh hat auf jeden Fall,
guten Publicity-Stand hingelegt, würde ich sagen, innerhalb der gedeihen Dienste so, weil ich meine äh alles, was da rauskommt, ich glaube, bei den anderen Geheimdiensten, da herrscht nur so dieses Gefühl vor, Mensch, Mensch, was die alles hinkriegen und so. Und wir.
Ja, das könnte echt also der dieser äh also inzwischen haben sie echt.
Nils alle auf. Ja.
Ne. Inzwischen haben sie den Effekt einfach mal so.
Das geht.
So früher wie Atomwaffentests, ne. Du machst mal so eine haben jetzt die Russen auch grade erst wieder gemacht, ne, irgendwie so eine äh das war, war doch vor ein paar Tagen die Meldung, irgendeine Rakete da, fotografiert von der ISS.
Keim war genau klar, wie die da, warum die auf der Stelle da rumgeflogen.
Die haben nicht die Rakete äh äh fotografiert, aber die haben die Rauchwolke, die dann sozusagen die Atmosphäre abgesetzt wurden, ganz gut sehen können aus der aus der ISS.
Genau und da gab's dann irgendwelche Hypothesen darüber, was was das jetzt da für ein.
Ja, irgendwie so eine Langstreckenrakete, die nicht ganz so äh lange flog und dann äh das Abbrennmanöver, was notwendig war, damit die dritte Stufe dann nicht äh irgendwo rausfliegt, wo sie nicht hin soll, erzeugt dann irgendwie so viel Qualm oder irgendwie sowas.
Ähm auf jeden Fall, genau, man man bekommt so den Eindruck, von ähm,
Das ist das ist der irgendwie um Raketentests handelt. Und die NSA jetzt irgendwie mal so angegeben hat und natürlich jetzt bestimmte andere Geheimdienste irgendwie dastehen und äh wahrscheinlich ihre Regierung kommen und sagen, ey Jungs, was ist denn da los so,
Ihr sagt immer, ihr hättet voll was drauf, aber äh guckt mal, was die NSA kann, was was könnt ihr denn?
Und ausgerechnet, also dass die ausgerechnet Russland geht jetzt, nachdem sie Snowden Asyl gewährt haben und sagen, ja, das ist ein
hier in Whistleblower, ne, für Demokratie und Menschenrechte, feiner Kerl, der darf bei uns hierchen unterkommen und so, ne? Äh ausgerechnet Russland vermeldet jetzt ja ähm
Also äh bisher war das ja so, dass der FSB, weißt du, wofür FSB steht? Nee, ne.
Ähm keine Ahnung.
Also ausgerechnet der FSB, der russische Inlandsgeheimdienst. Ähm war bisher äh,
dummerweise in der in der Situation, dass er,
Daten nur auf Anforderungen bekommen hat. Und jetzt erhält er im ab Juli zwanzig vierzehn ähm einmal alles. Ähm
völligen Zugriff auf die Internet- und Telefonverbindung, alle IP-Adressen und Telefonnummern
alle E-Mail-Adressen kontrollieren und sie dürfen auch Daten aus sozialen Netzwerken, Internettelefonaten und Chatchats abgreifen und außerdem wollen sie dann grundsätzlich schon mal ein bisschen üben bei den Winterspielen in Sotschi
Einfach mal alle Telekommunikationen voll überwachen. Haben sie sich überlegt.
Das klingt ein bisschen nach Planwirtschaft, oder? Die legen den Plan vorher fest.
Putin hat sie ja zumindest äh hat ja den Vorteil, dass er sich nicht noch so äh Republikaner da immer wieder eintritt, sondern er macht halt einfach und ähm weil ich glaube, die Republikaner ist auch das geringste Problem sind in den USA, ne, was so Überwachung betrifft
ähm wie auch immer,
Ja, das äh überrascht, glaube ich, ähm wenige, dass die Russen da jetzt so nachziehen. Mich überrascht das immer nur, dass das dann auch so äh klar herauskommt.
Aber die beschließen das halt einfach mal und äh Opposition ist da derzeit ohnehin äh abgeschafft. Das FSB ich werde mir jetzt mal die äh russische Bedeutung komplett schenken. Nicht, dass ich mich hier wieder blamiere mit meinen nicht vorhandenen russisch äh,
Kenntnissen, aber kurz übersetzt heißt das Bundesagentur für Sicherheit der russischen Föderation. Oder föderaler Dienst für Sicherheit der russischen Föderation, wenn man's,
wörtlich äh übernimmt. Ja, ja, die Sicherheit.
Hier werden sie jetzt, die werden einen Sitz auch für Sicherheit sorgen und das.
Ich glaube, das kommt echt wirklich auch nur äh das kommt echt so hin, wie du das sagst, ne? Das äh,
Der also wie man hätte jetzt also dass dass Putin das jetzt ausgerechnet macht, hätte man doch echt nicht also warum, ne? Man dachte er ist so,
Ich dachte, das ist jetzt Russland, die neue ähm.
Bewahrer der Freiheit und des Friedens und, und, und, und. Hm, tja, Schocking. Tja,
Also
Bin ja mal gespannt. Ich meine, den Chinesen ist es ja jetzt auch nicht so äh schlecht bekommen. Da haben sich ja noch alle äh total aufgeregt, dass äh noch nicht mal die Presse da unzensiertes Internet äh hatte in ähm
Bei den olympischen Spielen. Jetzt Sotschi wird bestimmt irgendwie weiß ich auch nicht
großer Aufreger im Westen oder in Deutschland vielleicht, da regen sich alle auf, der Rest interessiert's wahrscheinlich wieder mal gar nicht.
In Europa, also noch nicht mal jemanden ernsthaft aufgeregt, was die Briten da irgendwie für ein Theater veranstaltet.
Ja, das das finde ich nämlich jetzt eigentlich auch wirklich,
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch eine der ekligsten Auswirkungen an dieser Nichtreaktion, ja. Dass man jetzt eigentlich auch jegliche Legitimation äh für Kritik solcher Verhältnisse im Ausland verliert,
Wenn man sich also diesen diesen, diesen äh Umständen einfach in Deutschland nicht widersetzt,
dann sagen die Russen und die Chinesen und sagen alle einfach ja, was denn? Macht ihr doch auch,
Ihr diskutiert das der Onni, ja? Läuft einfach und fertig ist, äh, also, von daher.
Ist doch nur fürs für den Schutz.
Genau, ist ja nur für die Sicherheit. So sieht's aus. Wenn man da noch mehr zu sagen? Nö.
Diese Pflaumen sind echt. Aber so nach dem dritten, vierten Mal geht's.
Ja, dann will man dann doch immer noch ein bisschen mehr haben, ne.
Aal.
Ist wie mit der Überwachung, ne?
Am Anfang schmeckt's ein bisschen komisch, aber danach äh gewöhnt man sich. Ich äh erwähne nochmal die Räuspertaste. Die macht sich auch äh für für solche Sachen ganz gut, weil ich glaube dem geneigten Hörer will man jetzt nicht unbedingt immer noch so die Pflaume ins Ohr setzen, ne.
Kommen wir zum anderen äh Klassiker, die EU-Daten äh Schutzreform und ihr werdet es schon äh geahnt haben, dass auch vor allem der Grund, warum er Benjamin heute nochmal dazu äh geladen haben,
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal so ein bisschen ähm zusammenfassen, was da eigentlich jetzt so äh Previsle und Datenschutzreform,
passiert ist, weil ich glaube, das ist mal wieder so ein Thema, was so eine innere Komplexität hat, dass es einfach sehr schwierig ist, sich da jederzeit wieder äh einzuklinken, auch wenn wir hier schon relativ ausführlich mehrfach darüber berichtet haben.
Ich kann ja mal die die wichtigsten Punkte zusammenfassen, die bei mir hängengeblieben sind und Benjamin, du ergänzt.
Korrigierst dann. Genau, mach mal ein Management-Samary.
Also es geht um eine dieses Mal um eine Verordnung, das heißt, sie wird rechtlich bindend in allen Ländern der Europäischen Union.
Es handelt sich um ein,
Um das Vorkommen auf oder die Initiative auf EU-Ebene, die den bisher größten Ansturm an,
Lobbyisten äh nach Brüssel äh befördert hat. Genau. Und ähm was fällt mir noch dazu ein?
Es ist wichtig,
Und es ging äh insbesondere äh da um sehr viele Details, weil es gab, glaube ich, was waren es, wie viele hundert Änderungsanträge.
Waren über dreitausend an die viertausend.
An die viertausend Änderungsanträge, weil natürlich äh eine ähm,
ein ein, sagen wir mal, ein sehr restriktiver Datenschutz. Ähm für bestimmte
Geschäftspraktiken, die sich gerade im Internet so abspielen, ähm ein Todesstoß wäre. Ja, also wir wissen
dieses ganze Theater, was äh was Facebook da veranstaltet ist unter Datenschutz äh Gesichtspunkten, absolut inakzeptabel
und würde man da jetzt wirklich hart gegen vorgehen, könnte das soweit gehen, wie das die eben den das sie diesen Dienst gar nicht mehr anbieten können, beziehungsweise dass sie diesen Dienst nicht mehr gewinnbringend anbieten könnten, weil sie ja davon leben
die Daten der Menschen, die sie da äh bekommen, maximal auszuwerten. Ähm und äh,
Irgendwie gewinnbringend ähm zu vermarkten.
Ja, okay
Ja, dem würde ich auf jeden Fall nicht widersprechen zu den Geschäftsmodellen, die davon wirklich betroffen sind, können wir ja vielleicht nochmal später kommen. Also, was jetzt sozusagen prozessual zu sagen ist, dass äh dieser Vorschlag
für die Datenschutzgrundverordnung kam zweitausendzwölf aus der Europäischen Kommission, ist dann ans Parlament
und an den Ministerrat gegangen, also an den Rat der Justiz und Innenminister der Europäischen Union. Und was wir diese Woche erlebt haben, ist,
dass der das europäische Parlament seine Position zu dieser Datenschutzverordnung bestimmt hat. Und das haben sie gemacht, indem sie
das Gesetz sozusagen mit Änderungsanträgen kommentiert haben, Fraktionsweise sich Lobbyisten angehört haben, Bürgerrechtler angehört haben und jetzt äh im Innenausschuss des Europäischen Parlaments abgestimmt haben,
und sozusagen ihren Kommentar zu dieser Datenschutzverordnung entwickelt haben, mit diesem Kommentar,
mit dieser Meinung zur Datenschutzverordnung, die das Europäische Parlament jetzt hat,
der Berichterstatter, der Jan-Philipp Albrecht von den Grünen, dann in die Verhandlungen mit dem Ministerrat,
und mit der Europäischen Kommission, wobei man sagen muss, der Ministerrat ist noch nicht fertig.
Also der Ministerrat hat seine Position zu dieser Datenschutzverordnung noch nicht festgelegt, ist also noch gar nicht bereit für diese Gespräche, für die das Parlament und die Kommission jetzt bereit wären.
Das heißt, es gab überhaupt nur eine Abstimmung im Innenausschuss des Parlaments. Es gab keine Beschlussfassung des gesamten Parlaments.
Genau, das ist ein äh gängiges Prozedere im europäischen Parlament, dass man auf diese sogenannten,
normalerweise würde der Innenausschuss abstimmen, dann ginge die Sache ins Plenum des europäischen Parlaments dann äh,
und dann wurde man sich das ähm dann hätte man auch eine zweite Lesung, wie man's in Deutschland auch hat, eine zweite Lesung von Gesetzen im Bundestag
Und das Besondere ähm in der europäischen Konstellation ist allerdings, dass man sich dann, dass man in dieser zweiten Lesung des europäischen Parlaments wiederum die Position des Ministerrats
berücksichtigen müsste. Das heißt, man würde sich das Gesetz sozusagen zwischen den Kammern hin und her schieben und müsste immer wieder durchs Plenum, was sehr viel Zeit kostet.
Was man stattdessen macht, ist, man macht diese sogenannte. Das heißt, bevor dieses Gesetz das erste Mal das Plenum des Europäischen Parlaments sieht, hat man,
längst mit den Vertretern des Ministerrats und der Europäischen Kommission gesprochen, hat sich im Prinzip im besten Fall schon auf einen Entwurf geeinigt, den man dann einfach dem Parlament präsentiert und sagt,
Ja, wir sind schon fertig. Können wir abstimmen.
Mhm.
Und das hat den Vorteil, dass ersten schneller geht und zweitens braucht man bei dieser ersten Lesung ähm nicht die absolute Mehrheit, sondern äh,
Mehrheit, um's nicht so komplizierter zu machen, sondern einfach braucht man einfach eine.
Einfacher Mehrheit.
Genau, ich glaube, die einfache Mehrheit ist es dann.
Mhm.
Genau, das ist einfach, das ist das Prozessuale.
Äh
Und jetzt also ich fand das jetzt relativ kompliziert, aber ich tue mal so, als hätte ich das alles verstanden. Ähm was jetzt hier,
ist ähm.
Ist es, es aber übersprungen wurde und warum? Also ich habe gelesen, dass der ähm Jan-Philipp Albrecht jetzt ohne die erste Lesung direkt in die Verhandlung mit dem EU-Rad und mit der Kommission treten darf,
wie konnte nur der Innenausschuss das beschließen.
Es gibt so einen Code of Contact des Europäischen Parlaments, wo das geregelt wird, dass man das machen darf und das ist wie so oft im Europäischen Parlament, dass sich eine bestimmte Praxis
etabliert hat. Es gibt viele Sachen, die sind dort einfach gar nicht genau geregelt, weil der Vertrag von Lissabon ist ja auch erst zweitausendneun in Kraft getreten, deshalb sind bestimmte Verfahrensweisen noch gar nicht so etabliert,
und ähm es bilden sich dann so informelle
informelle Verfahren heraus. Das ist was, was man öfter im Europäischen Parlament sieht. Und dieses ist eins dieser äh informellen Verfahren, die sich so etabliert haben, aber ich glaube nicht erst seit einem Vertrag von Lisabon.
Aber trotzdem gab's ja dann doch eine relativ klare und deutliche Zustimmung. Also einundfünfzig zu eins bei drei Enthaltungen im Innenausschuss heißt ja, dass man eigentlich im Wesentlichen alle äh,
Parteien und Parteien zusammenschlüsse äh sich jetzt einig sind.
Genau und das hat man folgendermaßen erreicht, indem sich ähm
Der Berichterstatter und die Vertreter der anderen Fraktion, die dann Schattenberichterstatter heißen, äh die haben sich im
die haben sich im Hinterkämmerchen eingeschlossen, haben gesagt, ey Leute, wir können jetzt nicht über viertausend Änderungsanträge abstimmen, sondern wir einigen uns vorher
Position, weil sonst würde wahrscheinlich ein total unpraktikabler Entwurf herauskommen, weil,
Ach, wir wollen den Satz reinhaben, wir wollten den Satz, das wird dann kein Gesetz irgendwie. Genau und deshalb haben die sich sozusagen,
hinter verschlossenen Türen geeinigt, was auch ein gängiges Verfahren im Europäischen Parlament ist. Das heißt, die sind letzte Woche erst aus diesen Verhandlungen gekommen, haben gesagt, wir sind fertig, können wir abstimmen. Die Fraktionen sind sich einig,
Es passiert nicht immer das totale Einigkeit hergestellt wird, aber man hat's in diesem Fall tatsächlich geschafft.
So, das ist aber jetzt auch noch nicht das Last-Word, sondern jetzt,
Also wir werden's gleich nochmal anhören, was da jetzt eigentlich konkret äh beschlossen wurde, aber vielleicht kann man ja mal dieses Prozedere noch mal kurz zu Ende bringen, was die jetzt zu erwarten ist, wie es weiter äh geht.
Genau, also ähm der Jan-Philipp Albrecht äh wartet jetzt sozusagen auf den Ministerrat, bis der seine Position festgelegt hat und dann geht man in Dreiecksverhandlungen. Das heißt, die Kommission sitzt wieder am Tisch,
ähm der Jan Philipp als Vertreter des Parlaments und ähm dann der Ministerrat vertreten durch die aktuelle Ratspräsidentschaft,
und dann machen die sozusagen nochmal diese Art von Kompromissverhandlungen, versuchen aufeinander einzugehen und eine Konsensposition zu finden.
Genau und das macht man natürlich um Zeit zu sparen, weil äh das Europäische Parlament wird ja im Mai zweitausendvierzehn neu gewählt. Wir haben nächstes Jahr Europawahlen,
und
Genau, da will man da will man halt einfach, man will es halt durchkriegen. Es gibt zwar, es gibt zwar kein Discountersprinzip wie in Deutschland, das heißt, an den Gesetzen wird weiter gearbeitet, auch nach der Wahl. Trotzdem würde man erhebliche Verzögerungen reinkriegen,
und,
Die Kommission ändert sich ja auch. Das Europäische Parlament bestimmt ja auch ähm bestimmt ja auch bis zu einem gewissen Grad. Ähm die Kommission, die Kommission wechselt sich ja auch aus,
gleichen Tonus. Das heißt, äh die äh Kommissarin Reding, die da eine äh die da eine treibende Kraft ist
könnte dann unter Umständen auch raus sein aus diesem Prozess. Deshalb versucht man es so schnell wie möglich in der politischen Konstellation durchzuziehen.
Jedenfalls versuchen es die Befürworter der Datenschutzverordnung. Einige Mitgliedsstaaten wollen das nicht in der Geschwindigkeit durchziehen. Die sagen vor allem, ey, wir machen hier so ein wichtiges Gesetz. Wir müssen uns Zeit lassen, wir müssen
es ordentlich machen. Und auf dieser Welle reiten natürlich auch die Lobbyisten und sagen, ja ja, lasst mal lieber ordentlich machen.
Dass jetzt äh der aktuelle Stand äh äh gewissen Lobbygruppen so noch gar nicht passt. Äh was ist denn nun das Ergebnis? Also was ist der der Zwischenstand? Weil zuletzt wurde ja viel geklagt.
Das Ergebnis ist überraschend positiv im Sinne des Datenschutzes geworden. Also wenn man jetzt aus so einer,
Bürgerrechtlich Netzpolitischen Perspektive spricht, dann ist das Ergebnis sehr positiv geworden, ähm bestimmte Wünsche auch der Netzgemeinde in Anführungszeichen sind dort eingegangen,
Also zum Beispiel das Recht auf Datenportabilität ist klar durchgegangen und erhalten geblieben,
Das heißt, äh wenn sich das so fortsetzen würde, dann hätten wir,
Möglichkeit, unsere Daten von einem sozialen Netzwerk zum anderen mitzunehmen, wenn wir das wechseln wollen, zum Beispiel von Twitter zu App dot Net und müssten da nicht bei null anfangen, sowas ähnliches wie die Rufnummern, Mitnahme für digitale Dienste,
Das ist drin geblieben,
Dann ähm Datenschutzsymbole, beziehungsweise Privacy Icons, die ja schon lange auch im Netz gefordert wurden, sind äh eingegangen, auch wirklich formalisiert das Symbolsprache sein muss,
Also das ist so was wie wir bei kennen wir das ja. Man sieht, was man mit diesem.
Kopiert, darf verändert werden et cetera.
Und so eine so eine Sprache hat man jetzt auch, will man auch für Datenschutzregeln einführen, dass man sozusagen sieht, AR,
Daten werden Daten werden an Dritte gegeben, meinetwegen könnte ein so ein Warn-Icon sein.
Genau, darauf hat man sich geeinigt und man hat äh die Sanktion wieder erhöht. Das war ja eine ganz interessante Geschichte. Ursprünglich hatte die Europäische Kommission angedacht, dass man,
Unternehmen bei Datenschutzvergehen mit bis zu fünf Prozent des jährlichen weltweiten Jahresumsatzes bestrafen darf.
Schon eine Menge Holz sein kann.
Menge Holz sein, dann kam allerdings noch in der Schreibphase in der Kommission kamen allerdings die USA an, haben das rauslobbyiert,
und dann im ursprünglichen Kommissionsentwurf, der dann so ins Parlament gegangen ist, stand dann zwei Prozent nur noch, was ja schon ein Unterschied ist,
Parlaments hat's jetzt wieder auf fünf Prozent hochgesetzt. Das kann man jetzt irgendwie symbolisch finden, aber ist schon eine Ansage.
Das hat sich ja so lange Zeit nicht abgezeichnet. Kann man sagen, dass dieser ganze NSA-Skandal dazu beigetragen hat, dass äh hier sich die äh Gemüter anders entschlossen haben.
Das ist eine sehr interessante Frage, wozu es auch ganz unterschiedliche Meinungen in Brüssel und hier in Deutschland gibt. Ähm im Parlament wohl,
Obwohl sehr wohl, ich habe gehört, dass es geholfen hätte, auch konservative Abgeordnete zu überzeugen,
Allerdings und das ist allerdings, und das ist eher so meine Meinung ähm ist es, glaube ich, bei den,
Bei den Leuten da draußen nicht so richtig angekommen, weil
Man kann sich ja auch berechtigterweise fragen, verbindet man staatliche Überwachung mit ähm Datenschutz gegenüber Unternehmen. Das kann man sich ja, das ist ja eine legitime Frage, sich das äh,
Ja, ist eine legitime Frage, die man sich stellen kann. Also es gibt ja, es gibt ja die Leute, die sagen, ja, wenn Firmendaten sammeln, überhaupt gar kein Problem, wenn der Staat diese nutzt, schlecht,
Und es gibt äh die Leute, die da den Zusammenhang ganz klar machen und sagen, ja es gibt schon einen Zusammenhang zwischen,
Überwachung und staatlicher Überwachung. Das hängt dann auch so ein bisschen von der
ja davon ab, wo man politisch steht, finde ich. Und dann gibt's vielleicht noch eine dritte Gruppe, die sagt, ja, Datenschutz ist Verbraucherschutz, äh Unternehmen können bis zu einem bestimmten Grad machen
aber ich will Bescheid wissen und irgendwie Einspruchsrechte haben.
Was ist mit ähm hatte, wie würdest du den Einfluss von äh Lobbyplug hier,
sehen. Also Lobbyplug das äh,
Flaggiats Suchsystem, das zeigen konnte, welcher welche Europa Parlamentarier
streckenweise Änderungsvorschläge von Lobbygruppen einfach übernommen haben und dann in den, in den Prozess eingebracht haben
äh nachdem das jetzt alles gelaufen ist, wie würdest du da den den ähm den Einfluss dieses Projekts sehen?
Ja, mein Eindruck ist, dass es ähm ich glaube, es war es, es hat kurz eine Welle geschlagen,
relativ kurz ähm in der,
Ich glaube Anfang des Jahres war das so in etwa mit diesem Anfang zweitausenddreizehn genau und da hat's eine Welle geschlagen,
hat dieses hat dieses Thema nach oben gespürt,
hat hat hat dem einfach einen anderen Spin gegeben, man brauchte nicht mehr über diese komplizierten Regelungen reden, sondern konnte einfach über Lobbyismus in der EU reden und hat gleichzeitig über dieses Thema geredet,
Aber ich glaube, länger Fritzig hat es nicht,
diesen riesen Einfluss dann mehr gehabt. Also das also ich glaube, da ist sehr viel auch hinter den Kulissen passiert. Vor allem auch durch,
Ähm erstens durch die ja durch die Überredungskünste auch bestimmter Abgeordneter untereinander.
Dann denke ich, dann denke ich, haben ja auch die Bürgerrechtsorganisationen, haben ja dann auch viel auch Lobby hinter den Kulissen gemacht. Das könnte auch auf jeden Fall einen Einfluss gehabt haben. Aber dieses Lobby
Lobbyplug war, glaube ich, relativ kurzzeitig,
Da müsste man aber, glaube ich, auch nochmal mit Europaparlamentariern sprechen, die wirklich betroffen waren, also es hat die schon in dem Moment, es hat denen schon im Moment weh getan,
Also gerade zum Beispiel der Axel Voss von der CDU hat der schon ordentlich eins drauf gekriegt, dass er da ganz oben gelandet ist. Also es war ja schon daran, daran wird er auch öfter noch erinnert. Das hat dem, glaube ich, schon weh getan,
aber letztlich ist das, glaube ich, auch wieder aus dem Gedächtnis verschwund.
Ist denn das? Also ich meine, du sprichst jetzt im Wesentlichen, glaube ich, die politische Wirkung von Lobbyplug an. Die andere Frage ist ja, ist das Werkzeug als solches auch hilfreich gewesen für den Lobbyprozess?
Ja, ungemein. Also, es ist auf jeden Fall das, ich glaube,
fast besser als die Verordnung, die da jetzt rauskommt. Also, ich fand das echt ein klasse, ein klasse Tool, einfach um auch als Blogger, um damit zu arbeiten. Du konntest die Amentments im Volltext durchsuchen,
die so durchfiltern, das ist ja eine das ist ja eine Sache, die die lernen die im europäischen Parlament einfach nicht, die die geben die die in zehn PDFs,
Also das ist, es hat es einfach auf eine andere Stufe geholt. Auch die Usability, ähm zu sagen, ah, wo kommen die Abgeordneten her, die die schlechtesten Änderungsanträge gemacht haben oder was sind genau die Änderungsatri
Anträge zu Artikel XY, also da haben die das schon, also die die Jungs von Open Datas, die haben das da schon auf eine neue Stufe geholt,
Und das ist, muss ich sagen, auch eine Idee, auf die, glaube ich, die Brüssel Nerds, so wie ich, auch, auch glaube ich, so nicht gekommen wären, weil man da ähm,
braucht man, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen diese Datenjournalismusdenke, dieses wie wie bringen wir es rüber? Wie
Visualisieren wir's und ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass das so ähm die Leute, die sich die Blogger und so sind, meist eher so so textlastige Leute. Und das war ein sehr schöner Impuls von außen. Also das ist.
Aber du hast jetzt äh quasi die Bloggerperspektive jetzt eröffnet. Wie hast du auch einen Einblick, ob
jetzt die äh anderen Lobbykämpfer Netzaktivisten auf der einen Seite, aber auch die Parlamentarier selbst, äh das ähnlich äh sehen und äh auch für sich nutzbar gemacht haben
Oder denkst du, das Tool ist schon noch mehr eher erstmal ein Werkzeug, das der Öffentlichkeit.
Ich glaube eher Letzteres,
Also im Europäischen Parlament druckt man sich die Dinge aus und dann geht man da in seine Verhandlungen und da erstellen die sich untereinander für die Verhandlungen sowieso nochmal tausend andere kleine Textdokumente
oder Tabellen, wo die ihre.
Ich meine, dass das, dass das Parlament jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen äh wegen eines Tools komplett äh die Arbeitsmethoden ändert. Das ist mir klar, aber gibt es überhaupt,
Abgeordnete, die gesagt haben, oha,
Das äh ist jetzt die Art und Weise, wie ich auch künftig gerne diesen Prozess begleiten möchte für meine Arbeit.
Das würde ich, das würde ich auf jeden Fall nicht unterschreiben. Ich glaube, dann ist es doch eher ein Öffentlichkeitswirksames Mittel gewesen,
und hat halt vor allem Blogger und Netzaktivisten bevorteilt. Und auch Journalisten, das darf man nicht vergessen, also.
Ja
Einfach für die journalistische Recherche der Rest, also man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, die Lobby
Lobbyisten sage ich mal. Die haben ja auch sehr professionelle Strukturen aufgebaut. Ich glaube, die waren auf dieses Tool auch nicht mehr angewiesen. Da ist es so ähnlich wie im Europäischen Parlament, die da auch schon ihre Arbeitsweise entwickelt.
Ja. Ja gut, vielleicht deine Frage äh der Zeit, aber schon mal ganz interessant.
Genau.
Jetzt haben wir Features, du hast gesagt, die die Höchststrafe hast du, glaube ich, benannt. Ähm es gibt auch noch so eher so
rozedurale Zwänge irgendwie zu sagen, okay, wenn sensible Daten oder oder Daten von mehr als fünftausend äh betroffenen Personen irgendwie geliebt werden
ist man gezwungen, irgendwie einen Betriebsdatenschutzbeauftragten eine Risikoanalyse und eine Folgenabschätzung abliefern zu lassen. Ähm man hat eine Meldepflicht binden ähm zweiundsiebzig Stunden bei Betroffen
bei den Betroffenen. Das finde ich äh sportlich, also,
wenn man sich jetzt mal so ein großes League vorstellt. Es gab jetzt gerade vor einiger Zeit diesen Fall bei Vodafone. Ähm,
Die haben ja doch auch, denke ich, sehr, ja, so gut reagiert, wie sie's konnten. Denen sind diese Daten abhanden gekommen. Äh sie haben die betroffenen Personen,
persönlich äh schriftlich kontaktiert. Ähm,
und äh darauf hingewiesen, was jetzt welchem Risiko sie ausgesetzt sind. Das Ganze irgendwie in zweiundsiebzig Stunden finde ich äh.
Ja, ist schon echt äh ist ein sportliches Ziel, will ich jetzt nicht finden, will ich nicht kritisieren, ist auf jeden Fall, man sieht, da ist ein, da ist auf jeden Fall ein ein Anspruch drin, dann gibt's diesen,
Sie wollen jetzt irgendwie in Form Konten erzwingen, weil Datenverarbeitung, das heißt, es wird äh immer eine irgendwie große AGBs geben, die man äh denen man zustimmen muss.
Nee, gerade nicht. Also eigentlich ist ja die Idealvorstellung, dass wir, dass wir die, die Zustimmung zur Datenverarbeitung trennen,
von den, von den Geschäftsbedingungen oder von den anderen Vertragsbedingungen, dass man das einzeln sichtbar macht und
ähm was so gut ist oder gut sein soll an dieser Formulierung ist, dass man,
Es ist einfach im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes muss, müssen sich äh die Unternehmen irgendwas ausdenken, damit es expliziter passiert. Es geht nicht mehr mit vorangehakten Boxen und irgendwo in den AGBs versteckt. Also es muss
es muss halt gewisse Standards,
erfüllen und dieses Wörtchen das gab es so bisher noch nicht in der Datenschutzrichtlinie, die er gerade gilt und die dann die Länder in ihre eigenen Gesetze gegossen haben. Dieses Wörtchen gab's nicht, das heißt, hier kann man wirklich sagen,
Ähm hier hat man des Wortes eine Verstärkung eingebaut. Wie sich die dann praktisch zeigt, ist die nächste Frage
aber man hat hier zumindestens ein Zeichen gesetzt. Das ist genauso das gleiche wie mit der Meldepflicht. Es gibt immer die, es gibt natürlich immer von Juristen auch oder Praktikanten auch die richtige Bemerkung, dass das natürlich auch umsetzbar sein muss
da muss man natürlich auch sagen, dass das im Moment natürlich auch noch ein politisches Dokument ist. Das wird natürlich auch noch nachgearbeitet und so weiter und viele, viele Dinge werden auch einfach.
Viele Dinge werden im Datenschutz dann auch einfach ähm von den Datenschutzbehörden und so weiter,
ausgelegt. Also das, finde ich, sollte man immer auch nicht vergessen, dass es natürlich auch ein politisches Dokument in erster Linie ist.
Aber das also wie wie stelle ich mir das jetzt vor? Das heißt, ich kann Facebook Account machen. Also ist das, geht das um die Opt-In-Opt-Out äh Frage da?
Nee, es geht einfach, es geht einfach darum, dass ähm,
dass deine, dass deine Zustimmung, ich glaube, Facebook hatte schon sehr gut geregelt, deshalb ist das immer ein schlechtes Beispiel äh oder
diese klassischen Einwilligungsinternetdienste, die haben da schon irgendwie eine Art gefunden, damit umzugehen. Aber ich glaube, es geht einfach um,
umso, umso kleinstelligere Sachen, wo man irgendwie vorher dann erstens erst erfahren hat, ach so durch die Nutzung des Dienstes gebe ich ja hier meine Daten preis oder so,
Ich glaube, diese diese Angebote müssen, müssen's irgendwie nochmal überdenken und die Firmen müssen einfach klarer machen für was sie jetzt ähm um meinen Konsens irgendwie meine Einwilligung wollen,
darum geht's ganz einfach.
Und dann gibt's, glaube ich, den einen,
großen Kritikpunkt, der immer angebracht wird und das ist das der Begriff berechtigtes Interesse nicht definiert ist, weil es sich der jetzt richtig verstanden habe, der,
Das Textfragment darin befindet das ähm,
wenn die Unternehmen ein berechtigtes Interesse haben, äh personenbezogene Informationen auch ohne Zustimmung der Nutzer zu erheben,
dann dürfen sie das.
Genau. Da war ja immer die Forderung ähm aus aus bürgerrechtlicher Sicht. Entweder streichen wir das oder wir definieren klare Fälle, in denen es so ein berechtigtes Interesse geben könnte,
vorstellen, zum Beispiel irgendwie Fälle,
Fälle, wo jemand seine Rechnung nicht bezahlt oder so, wo man für wo man vielleicht sagt, okay, wir müssen externe beauftragen oder so, um das einzutreiben. Diese ganzen, diese ganzen Fälle von irgendwie Kreditbetrug und so weiter, okay,
Aber dann hätte man das halt einfach klar eingrenzen müssen, was man jetzt gemacht hat, ist, man hat den schon sehr wagenbegriff, äh versucht, näher zu definieren mit dem Begriff,
also
zu gut Deutsch, was man vernünftigerweise annehmen muss. Das heißt also, der Begriff des berechtigten Interesses wurde in dem Sinne nicht auf bestimmte Fälle eingeschränkt, sondern wurde jetzt nur so definiert,
dass das Unternehmen entscheiden muss, was der Nutzer vernünftigerweise erwarten könnte, wie es seine Daten benutzen wird.
Das heißt, wir haben eigentlich einen unklaren Begriff, nochmal mit einem unklaren Begriff aufgeladen.
Wir hatten doch letztens so einen Fall, wo es gesagt hat das nicht die US-Regierung gesagt? Wo sie sagten, ey Jungs, ihr könnt doch, ihr habt doch nicht,
Das war doch diese Meterdatenerfassung bei ATNT Seite äh.
Dass die Leute das ja auch erwarten würden.
Genau, dass man sagen würde, ihr werdet doch nicht ernsthaft glauben, dass wir das nicht machen
Das ist ja wohl klar. Also ähm wäre das nicht eigentlich dann die Vektor in dem ganzen Gesetz, dass man da ein paar hundert Seiten aufschreibt und am Ende heißt es, es sei denn, es ist es ist
Man könnte von einem halbwegs äh gesunden Menschen erwarten, dass er das weiß, dass dass die Daten da alle gesammelt und ausgeschlachtet.
Genau, das das könnte natürlich so ein Schlupfloch werden, wobei man sagen muss, in den sogenannten Erwägungsgründen wieder ein neues Fachwort, Erwägungsgründe sind die ähm,
sind sozusagen Paragraphen, die die jeweiligen Artikel eines Gesetzes nochmal ein bisschen ausführen,
sind nicht rechtsbindend, aber die sind halt zur Erklärung nochmal da. Und in den Erwägungsgründen hat man denn versucht, bestimmte äh Fälle zu spezifizieren. Was man allerdings da wieder gemacht hat und das so die nächste Sache
wo ich überhaupt nicht mit einverstanden bin, ist, dass man gesagt hat, bei sogenannten Pseudonym-Daten kann der Datenverarbeiter, also das Unternehmen
vernünftigerweise davon ausgehen, dass ähm dass der Nutzer weiß, dass seine Daten verarbeitet werden.
Und das kann man jetzt und da gibt's jetzt verschiedene Interpretationen von diesen Pseudonymen Daten. Also einmal trifft es natürlich diesen ganzen Bereich Web-Tracking, ganz eindeutig. Dort haben wir irgendeine Sache,
Dort sind wir mit 'nem Identifier unterwegs der wie auch immer passiert, also wie der auch immer gesetzt wird, der uns wiedererkennt,
Maßen, also dieses trifft, das trifft diese Web-Tracking-Problematik. Man sagt also, alles in dem Bereich wird wahrscheinlich und das äh berechtigte Interesse fallen.
Und ähm das sind jetzt ähm das sind jetzt so,
erste, ja, erste Ideen, die so auf Madinglisten kamen, auch von Leuten, wo ich denke, dass die sich damit auskennen könnten, dass es vielleicht eben genau dieses Rechtsschlupfloch werden könnte von dem Linus gesprochen hat, dass nämlich ähm,
Unternehmen, das nämlich auch große Unternehmen sagen können, hey, was wir machen,
Ist doch, sind doch Pseudonyme Daten, weil äh wir haben diese Daten einmal erhoben und damit wir die besser in unseren Datenbanken korrigieren können und so weiter,
setzen wir eh Ordnungsnummern für die Fest, das heißt das heißt das machen wir eh und so könnte man natürlich sagen, ist alles was in diesen ganzen Datenbanken passiert,
und die Weitergabe damit legitim, solange dem Datensatz eben ein anderer Identify, sondern irgendwie eine Ordnungsnummer zugewiesen wurde
Das ist so ein bisschen die, sage ich mal, paranoidere Interpretation, wo man einfach gucken muss, inwiefern sind große Unternehmen und deren Rechtsabteilung darauf angewiesen, sich auf solche Ausflüchte zu beziehen.
Aber die ganze Problematik des Web-Tracking ist, denke ich, davon eher getroffen,
Was nehme ich auch zu einem anderen Kritikpunkt passt, nämlich ähm dem Profiling Paragraph,
wo man gesagt hat, die Profilbild, die automatische Profilbildung, zum Beispiel auf Basis von Algorithmen ähm erfordert nicht immer eine Zustimmung,
sondern erfordert nur eine Zustimmung, wenn äh wenn der Nutzer davon daraus negative Konsequenzen haben könnte,
erhebliche Konsequenzen, so ist, glaube ich, die Formulierung oder rechtliche oder rechtliche Folgen erwartbar wären,
Das heißt natürlich auch wieder, dass so ein Profiling, auf sage ich mal, softeren Niveau,
bei Web-Tracking und so passiert generell davon ausgenommen ist. Das heißt, kurz gefasst, wir haben wahrscheinlich ein für diese ganzen Tracking-Mechanismen,
Was ich schon finde ich auch eine Ansage ist, weil ähm,
Ja, wir haben mit dieser Tage auch immer wieder diese Meldungen. Ja, Google arbeitet an neuen Verfahren, um irgendwie, um irgendwie Leute auch über Geräte tracken zu können und so,
Und da finde ich, ist es schon eine Ansage zu sagen, okay, da das bedarf nicht der Nutzerzustimmung, sondern äh wir sagen ja, wir sagen jetzt, dass das erstmal okay ist und dass wir, dass wir das als sehen.
Es ist für mich schon eine, ist für mich schon eine Grundsatz
eine grundlegend andere Ausgangsposition, wenn man sagen kann, es wird normal äh unsere Bewegung im Netz zu erfassen und das ist generell nur und nicht optinwürdig.
Also.
Aber das ist doch nicht gut oder sagst du.
Das ist das ist nicht gut. Nee, nee, auf jeden Fall. Ich finde nur weil ich ja letztens dafür kritisiert wurde, dass ich hier so rumgehetzt habe, habe ich's heute mal versucht, ein bisschen zu versachlich,
und ich ich finde schon, dass das das ist schon eine Ansage und ich weiß
Ich bin kein Experte in so Prozessen wie diesem Donald Track, wo man versucht irgendwie Standards dafür zu finden, darf ich getrackt werden? Ja oder nein, wird über meinen Browser übermittelt. Dieses Verfahren schleift ja sowieso und ich weiß nicht, ob es solche Verfahren und das
wenn die Unternehmen daran kein Interesse haben, sich weiter an diesen Tisch zu setzen, weil ähm die Leute müssen ja eh nicht zustimmen,
zu ihrer Tracking-Werbung,
Kann man natürlich so und so argumentieren. Industrielobbyisten würden vielleicht sagen, nee, jetzt haben wir gerade, jetzt haben wir gerade einen Grund, weil ihr es uns nicht verbietet.
Ich wurde umgekehrt argumentieren, nee, wir haben, ihr habt jetzt, ihr habt jetzt erst gar keinen Grund, euch mehr an den Tisch zu setzen bei euer Geschäftsmodell ist sowieso erlaubt. Und ihr müsst euch nicht bemühen, wie ihr da noch eine Einwilligung von den Leuten bekommt.
Elektronischem Wege, wie zum Beispiel bei.
Also Licht und Schatten, aber wenn ich's mal richtig äh mitbekommen habe, dann würde ich sagen, grundsätzlich äh äh kann man
sagen, ist das jetzt erstmal so schlecht nicht gelaufen
nur dass natürlich jetzt noch äh alles nicht vorbei ist, sondern es steht jetzt vor allem noch diese knifflige Dreiecksverhandlung äh im Raum, um uns natürlich davon auszugehen, dass hier nochmal die nationalen Interessen oder die Kommissionsinteressen äh dem Ganzen nochmal versuchen, einen anderen Spin zu geben.
Genau und und man weiß halt
noch nicht, deshalb sind alle Einschätzungen bisher auch ein bisschen vage. Dieses Profiling und Interest ist das, was ich jetzt vertreten kann hier
tatsächlich ein Schlupfloch ist. Diese Verordnung wurde noch nicht komplett durchgesehen und analysiert, also grad geht's so los, dass die ersten Artikel und Einschätzungen dadrüber wahrscheinlich meine man hat Montag dadrüber abgestimmt,
und dann weiß man natürlich nicht, was dieses Pseudonomität Schlupfloch, was das alles noch erlauben wird. Das kann man natürlich jetzt,
nicht sehen, sondern im schlimmsten Fall erst, wenn's zu spät ist. Und weiterhin,
äh muss man natürlich sagen, dass die Fallhöhe natürlich vielleicht auch noch nicht hoch genug ist für so Verhandlungen mit dem Ministerrat, weil man, weil man gesagt hat,
okay, ähm ich bin okay, bei Profiling und berechtigtem Interesse sind wir zu Zugeständnissen bereit,
und dass das ähm das das hier vielleicht noch weiter das hier vielleicht in den Verhandlungen noch weiter drauf eingehauen wird, vor allem, wenn dann auch wieder die Lobby übers Minister, über den Ministerrat ins Spiel kommt,
Also hier ist hier ist halt hier ist halt grundsätzlich die Aussage, hätte man, hätte man nicht vielleicht was noch stärkeres verabschieden müssen, um eine noch stärkere Verhandlungsposition zu haben.
Leuchtet ein, aber der nächste Schritt ist also jetzt, dass der Jan-Philipp Albrecht im Prinzip,
Alleine dann da diese das Ding,
aushandelt. Ach so und dann kommt der wahrscheinlich damit zurück in sein in sein Parlament beziehungsweise in seinen Ausschuss und sagt äh,
Guck mal hier, das habe ich mit denen ausgehandelt. Ich empfehle das anzunehmen und dann wird ihm geantwortet, äh kannst knicken oder im Zweifelsfall, ja, klar machen wir so wie du das hast.
Genau, so in etwa, so in etwa muss man sich das vorstellen. Wobei natürlich alles unter dem Vorbehalt steht,
werden die sich einigen. Ich meine, der Ministerrat kann immer noch sagen, hey, wir sind noch gar nicht zu einer gemeinsamen Position gekommen. Jetzt sind Europawahlen ein halbes Jahr später ändert sich die Kommission hups,
Also das ist natürlich also es ist noch gar nicht gesagt, dass diese Dreiecksverhandlungen rechtzeitig beginnen können. Das ist glaube ich.
Ist es denn äh eine realistische Szenario, dass der Ministerrat das absichtlich verschleppt äh um da eine oder gibt's da irgendwelche Leute, denen zuzutrauen ist, dass sie es äh machen?
Auf jeden Fall. Also, ich würde sagen,
Großbritannien, Irland sind da relativ verdächtig dafür, Deutschlands Rolle kann man nicht so richtig einschätzen. Deutschland hat man am Anfang sehr stark kritisiert und
und die werden auch immer noch kritisiert, wobei ich sagen muss, ich habe das Gefühl, die haben sich gebessert
wir wir hatten bei der digitalen Gesellschaft auch mal Gespräche mit dem Innenministerium, da fand ich das gar nicht mehr so unvernünftig. Aber
Deutschland versteckt sich immer hinter diesem Totschlagargument, das wäre handwerklich noch nicht gut.
Bräuchte Zeit ums handwerklich gut zu machen. Das ist das, was ich vorhin auch meinte mit diesem eher politischen Entwurf, den wir jetzt haben,
Also das ist sowas, wo man sich bei Datenschutzgesetzgebung vielleicht bei jeglicher Gesetzgebung auch sehr gut hinter verstecken kann, dass man sagt, oh, oh, oh, nee. Das wird nicht praktikabel sein, da müssen wir noch mehr dran arbeiten.
Ja, das äh dieses handwerklich nicht gut von Hans Peter Friedrich, kann ja auch langsam nicht mehr hören, also das äh also handwerklich nicht gut. Das ist.
Handwerk. Es ist echt, der geht auch mit so einer, ja, der hält das wohl alles irgendwie für ein Handwerk, der Mann.
Und noch.
Handwerklich nicht gut, was was erlaubt der sich irgendwie überhaupt ein Urteil über irgendwas, was ein anderer Mensch macht.
Nee, das tun wir ja auch.
Ja, aber wir wir sind nicht.
Ja, wobei man sagen muss, wobei man natürlich sagen muss, dieses handwerklich nicht gut.
Es ist nicht, es ist wahrscheinlich.
Ist nicht schon ganz von der Hand zu weisen und.
Weil er so viel Patchwork wahrscheinlich passiert ist, ja.
Sozusagen dem Netzaktivismus nahestehende Juristen, die diese Position, zumindestens für den Kommissionsvorschlag vertreten haben und da die Parlamentsposition jetzt wieder so ähnlich ist, wie dieser Kommissionsvorschlag,
ist das Problem wahrscheinlich immer noch auf dem Tisch. Ich würde das jetzt nicht ganz von der Hand weisen,
Was noch ein ganz interessanter Spin ist, jetzt kommen ja auch die Lobbyisten wieder verstärkt ins Spiel, jetzt die aus den Hinterzimmerverhandlungen waren die ausgeschlossen, aber jetzt können sie es ja über den Ministerrat nochmal probieren. Da habe ich gelesen, dass es vielleicht,
deren Interesse sein könnte, die Verhandlungen so lange aufzuhalten,
bis wir wiederum die Verhandlungen zum transatlantischen Freihandelsabkommen haben, um dann um dann irgendwie
Darüber hin Hebel zu kriegen, zu sagen, oh nee, so werden wir uns nie auf ein Freihandelsabkommen einigen können, wenn wir hier so starke Datenschutzregeln in Europa haben.
Das äh dieser Spin der Industrie könnte noch erwartbar sein. Fazit also,
Auch wenn, auch wenn man dieses Verfahren jetzt höchst undemokratisch finden kann, dass die das schon wieder hinter verschlossenen Türen irgendwas machen, ist es wahrscheinlich aus einer Datenschutzperspektive das Beste, das zu pushen,
je mehr es verzögert wird, je schlechter wird's wahrscheinlich und je mehr kriegt es die Handschrift der Industrie.
Ja, dem habe ich jetzt nicht mehr viel äh hinzuzufügen, du Linus?
Nee, ich fand das sehr, äh, sehr interessant und sehr ausführlich und äh, hat mich sehr gefreut, vielen Dank.
Habe ich euch ganz schön zugelabert, oder?
Nee, ich finde, das ist einfach mal das ein komplexes Thema. Offensichtlich und ähm ich bin froh, dass wir da jetzt äh dich nochmal zu Gast hatten, um da ähm.
Genau, das müssen wir erst mal äh auseinander, Klambücher bekommen.
Licht reinzubringen, genau.
Das bringt uns dann aber auch schon äh zum Ende der Sendung, oder?
Traue mich nicht so richtig.
Ist der Geschmack der Demokratie.
Ich mag schon nicht so ein Trockenobst. Ich weiß nicht, ob das.
Feuchtobst ist eine Einzel verschweißte Traube.
Na gut, für die Action.
Traube ist gut. Pflaume.
Pflaume, stimmt, Pflaume.
Es ist so der Geschmack der Freiheit und der großen Koalition.
Video-Podcasting. Für sowas braucht man Video-Podcast.
Leute.
Am Anfang saß sehr gut aus. Ja, also ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr habt.
Verpackt gefallen die mir gut.
Ja verpackt war das alles noch super.
Haben die die in irgendwas eingelegt in Essig oder.
Sitzt doch mal so. Ja klar, so ist das eingelegt.
Okay, ich dachte, die wachsen so.
Ja aber siehst du mal so, am Ende seid ihr nicht gestorben daran. Also kann es so schlecht nicht gewesen sein.
Das dauert aber auch länger, wenn man äh an Nahrung, an Nahrungsmitteln stirbt. Das also es geht über eine Podcast-Episode hinaus. Üblicherweise.
Ja, aber man gewöhnt sich ja an alles. Schlimmerweise.
Auch an so eine Nahrungsmittel vergiften.
Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas anzukündigen? Passiert irgendwas? Äh, sowas wichtig und wichtig?
Was ich vielleicht noch ganz wichtig fand, ist, wir haben ja am Anfang über die Koalitionsverhandlungen geredet, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitgekriegt habt. Gestern ist so ein bisschen durch die sozialen Netzwerke gegangen, dass ähm das Thema Netzpolitik ähm,
unter Gruppe der,
Verhandlungsgruppe Kultur in den Koalitionsverhandlungen behandelt werden soll. Ich hab da auf jeden Fall so ein Dokument gesehen, da stand irgendwie Gruppe X Y, Kultur
und als Unterpunkt digitaler Agenda
Das ist, glaube ich, auch nicht so der beste Ausgangspunkt, wenn man äh Netzpolitik unter Kulturpolitik subsummiert.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich, dass dieses ganze, dass die ganzen Rechtspolitiker äh über die harten Sachen ohne die Netzpolitiker reden werden und bei Kultur erinnert mich so an Urheberrecht und Schutzfristen und so,
Das fand ich noch einen ganz interessanten Fakt. Also so ernst meint es die Parteien im Moment damit. Also CDU und SPD.
Gibt Wichtigeres sehen wir natürlich anders.
Ähm.
Oder wir nennen uns um. Logbuchkulturpolitik.
Netzkultur.
Mir äh ich würde dann noch äh eins ankündigen,
weil die nächste Sendung nach dem Jahrestag von Lokbuch Netzpolitik ist,
Ja, das steht nämlich bei mir im Kalender und das heißt, am achtundzwanzigsten Januar, ja, ja, schön, achtundzwanzigsten November,
Wenn wir zwei.
Hammer.
Die nächste Sendung ist wahrscheinlich erst am darauffolgenden Donnerstag.
Äh ja, das wird sich noch zeigen. Äh November könnte noch etwas ruppig werden in der Zeitplanung. Nun gut.
Dann können wir noch fürs Wochenende werben, aber jetzt wahrscheinlich eh zu spät, um dann noch äh Karten zu bekommen. Oder gibt's noch einige wenige.
Ist jetzt vielleicht hier nicht so ganz die Zielgruppe, aber wo du jetzt das schon mal aufgebracht hast, ja, wir machen unser zweites Podcaster Meeting,
nach einem halben Jahr das zweite äh wieder in Berlin. Da gibt's mehr dazu auf Meter Ebene Punkt M E. Wer da noch kurzentschlossen ist, noch sind noch ein paar Tickets zu haben.
Und ja, das äh findet statt. Dieses Wochenende und wird sicherlich ganz,
Ganz nett. Sonst ist noch Zeitumstellung.
Zeitumstellung auch noch jetzt am Sonntag oder was?
Gibt's überhaupt eine Arbeitsgruppe in der Koalition zur Abschaffung der Sommerzeit? Nee, nee. Das ist wirklich die Sachen, die man auf die man mal achten sollte.
Ist jetzt echt am siebenundzwanzigsten Zeitumstellung oder was?
Mhm.
Erstmal wieder darüber nachdenken, ob's jetzt eine Stunde vor oder eine Stunde zurück ist. So diese Dinge mit der mit obwohl es irgendwie zweimal im Jahr einen beschäftigt, kommen trotzdem.
Stunde zurück.
Nee, Faustregel, im Winter kannst du immer länger pennen oder die Nacht ist eine Stunde länger, wie du das siehst. Also im Oktober, wenn du bei der Oktoberzeitumstellung kann man immer länger pennen, bei der Sommerzeitumstellung muss man früher aufstehen.
Mehr finde ich, muss man gar nicht wissen.
Äh ich habe ich ähm.
Stunde länger pennen, würde dir, glaube ich, durchaus entgegenkommen.
Soll ich mal erklären, was ich hier, was ich heute, ich würde das jetzt abschließend, wenn ich das erzählen, wenn man sich hier so über mich lustig macht? Ähm ich,
bin Gäste, habe gestern meinen Flug verpasst und bin dann irgendwann noch äh kurz vor Mitternacht in ein Airport-Hotel eingecheckt und bin da heute Morgen um fünf Uhr aufgewacht äh um nach Berlin zu fliegen und hier eine Sendung zu machen.
Das nenne ich Wacker Linus.
Frage nicht, was du für Meter ebene Netzpolitik tun kannst,
Äh weißt du was? Siehst du, ich bin müde.
Äh nee, ich Marta, weil Marte ist auch alle.
Ist auch alles ist furchtbar.
Katastrophale Bedingungen. Wir ernähren uns hier von sauren Pflaumen, keine Mate, schlafen an Flughäfen.
Alles nur für die Demokratie. Ich sage tschüss.
Herzlichen Dank, Benjamin.
Bitte.
Bis bald.